in a very deep sense the brain is who we
are and so by looking at what it's made
up of what its pieces are and what each
piece does i think that's starting to
sketch for us
a picture of the mind
today on chalk radio we're exploring our
most critical biological asset
our brain
i'm your host sarah hansen
my guest this week is a scientist and
mit professor who studies the
architecture of the brain
i'm nancy kenwisher and i'm an
investigator in the mcgovern institute
for brain research
and a member of the department of brain
and cognitive sciences
and i study the human brain and how it's
organized at a very
macro scale level i'm interested in big
parts of the brain and what they do
in addition to being an investigator
nancy kanwisher is a founding member of
the mcgovern institute which is a
community of neuroscientists who are
working to better understand the brain
i was curious how nancy got into her
field of research and the advancements
that have developed over the years since
she's been working in it
when i started in cognitive psychology
the methods we had available were pretty
rudimentary
i measured reaction time and accuracy
when people did simple tasks looking at
pictures and understanding sentences
and from that very
sparse low-tech data of people's
responses behavioral responses and
different tasks
we tried to infer the algorithms running
in their heads
and that's kind of like trying to figure
out how a car works just by driving it
around
and you could discover some stuff you
could figure out you could probably
figure out that there's something like
gear shifts just by studying its
behavior
you could figure out a bunch of things
about car engines just by driving them
around
you could figure out even more once you
study the different ways that cars break
down like okay sometimes they have this
problem and sometimes they have that
problem and then from that you could
infer even if you didn't know anything
before
what the different pieces of a car
engine might do
so for a long time that's what our field
had it's basically
driving brains around and studying what
happens when they break down
but then more recently
these amazing methods came along that
enabled us to look inside
and so in my first year in graduate
school
the first non-invasive study of function
in the human brain was published on the
cover of science
and here was this unbelievably blurry
picture but nevertheless a picture
of activity in the back of the head
where visual cortex resides
and that picture just blew my mind
and
i wrote to every brain imaging lab in
the world there were only about five
back then
and i said i have these ideas for
experiments and i sent them my proposals
and uh you know crickets
and so i kept at it and it was literally
10 years before i got to do a brain
imaging experiment
spending a lot of that time beating on
the doors trying to get access to the
machines but the machines were big and
expensive
they were controlled mostly by mds who
to be blunt about it didn't really know
what psychological questions to ask
because that's not their field we
psychologists are the ones with the
questions we were the ones who were
studying minds and who knew what to look
for in brains but we psychologists
didn't get to use the big fancy machines
for another decade
and then it's been really quite a party
since then
nancy explained to me that our most
basic understanding of the brain has
been known for a long period of time
100 years or more and interestingly some
of the most astounding discoveries have
come not from studying the healthy brain
but by studying damaged ones
more recently with new technologies such
as functional mri which is a specific
type of mri that scans for metabolic
function in the brain
we've been able to expand and grow our
knowledge in ways that provide
information that's far more specific
than we've ever had before
for
a couple hundred years we've had the
idea
that regions in the left side of the
lateral temporal and frontal lobes are
involved in processing language
and we've known that because people who
have damage to those regions sometimes
lose their language abilities
and similarly we knew that somewhere in
the back of the right hemisphere near
the bottom
there was some kind of function that was
involved in face recognition
and again we knew that from the small
number of people
who had damage to that part of the brain
and lost their ability to recognize
faces
sometimes without losing their ability
to recognize objects or words or scenes
and that was strongly suggestive that
hey maybe there's a special bit of the
brain
for face recognition
that kind of stuff has been known for a
long time
but that was kind of it
right and then functional mri came along
and now we have dozens of regions of
cortex
where we have a pretty good idea of what
each of those little patches of cortex
does
and many of those regions do very very
specific things like just thinking about
what other people are thinking or just
understanding language or just face
recognition
facial recognition
that's a topic that gets talked about a
lot at my house
mostly because my spouse seems to
struggle with it
i was curious if this was typical
never mind brain damage take perfectly
normal people you test a hundred of them
on their face recognition abilities and
what you find is that those abilities
are widely varying
and some people are just awful like the
bottom two people in your group of a
hundred those bottom two people
routinely fail to recognize family
members i mean that's really bad
and the top two percent of people are so
good
that they routinely hide it from others
because other people would find it
creepy
so i live with someone who's pro on a
scale of one to ten probably a three i
would say i'm about a six
and where would you put yourself i'm
about a two or a three i'm really bad
i have to ask my partner when we're
watching a movie is that the protagonist
said the other one is that
no i'm bad yeah well
while each individual part of the brain
is uniquely important one big takeaway
nancy explained is that every mental
function requires many brain regions and
understanding that is key to
understanding how the brain operates as
a whole
nothing lives in just one piece of the
brain so even when i carry on about how
some parts of the brain do what very
specific things
that doesn't mean that they do that very
specific thing alone
every mental function requires many
different brain regions the part that's
involved in face recognition could not
do its task without getting input from
primary visual cortex and other basic
visual regions
and there would be
no use of face recognition if it didn't
send its information to other parts of
the brain that know things like like
your rolodex of people you have that
someplace in the brain it's not very
well understood but someplace you know
all the facts you know about the people
you know
and so each of those brain regions acts
in concert with lots of other brain
regions
it's one thing to understand how the
brain works in the abstract
but in her course 9.13 the human brain
nancy connects neuroscience with
something much more personal she begins
the semester with a story
a personal anecdote she uses to paint a
picture of all the various topics she
seeks to introduce in her class
it's widely recognized that people like
stories and people resonate to stories
there's a whole
developing
meme and science communication about how
you're supposed to tell stories and for
a long time it's like yeah i know i'm
supposed to tell a story but i just have
my lectures and i don't know i don't
know what story to tell
you know i was just sort of and then i
saw oh my god i do have a story
and i was psyched to realize that
actually
that story
echoes to an eerie degree all of the
themes of the course
and it's the story of a friend of mine
who had a brain tumor
which was revealed very dramatically
when he
collapsed on the floor at my house
unconscious horrifying terrifying but it
pulls people in right away um he's fine
now to get to the chase totally fine but
in between there was quite a scary and
fascinating uh set of developments in
which he had a benign tumor
that was pressing against a region of
his brain that my lab had studied
that's involved in knowing where you are
and i knew this guy pretty well and so i
had actually been noticing for a few
years that he
seemed to have lost his ability to
navigate around in the world and it
scared me and worried me but i just
didn't even
you know make myself think about it
and so
you know i should have known what was up
with this guy you know i i had all the
data in front of me and i somehow didn't
until he collapsed on the floor and it
kind of all came together and i thought
oh my god what's going on with his brain
and further
eerily we had actually scanned him in
one of the standard experiments in my
lab many years before
and so
when he called me
you know after he collapsed he and you
know he
recovered a minute or two later and
spent the day in the er while they're
trying to figure out what was happening
with him and
all day long the er docs are saying oh
this is a hard thing this is whatever
we'll figure it out
and after test after test after test
that night he calls me and he says get
over here right now they found something
in my brain
so i was just horrified and as i'm
driving over to the er
i called one of my lab techs and i said
hey you know we scanned this guy years
ago
see if you can dig around in the files
and find the anatomical scans we would
have made when we did that brain study
and so by the time i got there
the mri tech did something they're
probably not supposed to do but they
showed him and me pictures of his brain
with this huge thing the size of a lime
right in the middle of his brain is just
horrifying
and then i was able to look at the
images that my lab had collected
quite a few years before
and we could see it
even many years before it was much
smaller
but clearly visible
and that was very important clinically
because
it showed that this was a very slow
growing tumor and that was good news
and very diagnostic about what kind of
tumor it was
as scary as this experience was
not just for nancy but also for her
friend
it led to some important discoveries
nancy was able to test and receive
results in real time about how her
friend's navigation ability was impacted
by the tumor
because of this she was able to confirm
her own research about how his ability
to navigate the world around him was
impacted by the tumor pressing down on a
specific region of his brain
in the whole process of
watching my friend go through this
i tested him on a bunch of tasks
he was totally game it's like try
drawing a floor plan of your apartment
and he draws this total mess i mean it
just
you know i've been in his apartment i
know what the floor plan is and what he
drew had just no relation whatsoever
and then i said okay try drawing a floor
plan of the upstairs of my house we were
in the downstairs of my house right then
[Music]
couldn't do it
and then i thought well maybe it's just
complex multi-part images right things
that are hard to reconstruct so i said
okay try drawing a sketch of a bicycle
[Music]
so he draws a bicycle it was not
beautiful but it was clearly
recognizable it had all the right parts
in the right positions
and that's you know a very low-tech
simple example of one of the main
methods in my field is studying people
with brain damage and trying to analyze
exactly what is it
that's messed up and what is it that's
preserved and that shows you this kind
of implausible split why would you be
able to
remember the visual appearance of places
but not the visual appearance of objects
but that's exactly what actually my own
research predicted
[Music]
i asked nancy how our students respond
to hearing this story
she told me that students respond by
asking questions
this idea of investigating questioning
and really holding on to curiosity
is exactly what's at the heart of
nancy's teaching
they proceed to ask all the questions
that are the basic
questions that we're going to explore in
the course like i just tell them the
story and then they say okay
did it get better how long did you know
what other symptoms did he have did he
have this particular other thing did it
affect other things besides scenes
how would you study it besides mri when
you you know on and on and on with it's
like every single question they ask
these are just the questions we ask in
my field which is one of the things i
love about this field is that it's not
like quantum mechanics you don't need to
study for years and years and years
before you even have the mental space
where you can frame the questions like
all of the questions of interest in my
field are questions that any normal
person can ask with no background
whatsoever
that's the cool thing about the brain is
like we have one and we get to use it
and we get to watch it in action right
and we have already been wondering all
these questions whether we realize it or
not
right i mean one of my favorite things
to point out is
is that lots of questions that people
have been wondering about anyway like
how solid is human knowledge like we
think we know this stuff do we really
know it are we fooling ourselves those
are questions that can be asked in lots
of different ways but one of the ways of
asking them
is to look at brain development and
where the structure of the brain comes
from
the kinds of questions that you can ask
and sometimes even answer in my field
are questions that lots of people wonder
about
this was a particularly powerful part of
the conversation for me
the idea that this kind of study is
accessible
that's not something you typically infer
when you hear cognitive neuroscience
nancy can wisher wants to change that
part of her mission is to allow everyone
access to the knowledge generated by the
field
you know the public pays for the science
we do in the lab and so i think it's a
moral obligation of scientists to give
back
and i think i'm in the lucky position
that the stuff i do is easily shareable
with people and so
i think it would be just not okay not to
share it and so i try to share it
whenever i can
but it's also fun like it's really fun
to get idea across and see somebody
resonate to it so i think an educational
goal that i don't think i've quite
figured out how to do but that i aspire
towards
is to kind of give people a push
and encourage them to find a few things
because that will teach them that they
can then go find more on their own
i would love it if some of my research
would actually help people
but it would be a lie if i told you that
that's why i do it or that we have
already been able to help a lot of
people that's just not true
the real thing that motivates me is i
just think it's like the grandest
scientific quest of all time to
understand the human mind and looking at
a brain is a great way to do that so
that's really what i'm in it for is just
the pure fascination of understanding
our own minds
to me it's like all about
sharing things that i think are cool
because actually my teaching goal
is to blow people's minds
blowing people's minds by teaching about
them
it's one of the things that makes
nancy's course so compelling
and by the way i asked nancy if there
were insights about teaching that she
wished our listeners would share with
her
well there are all kinds of topics that
i haven't figured out how to lecture on
that i just have a blind spot on like
memory this is a big part of the field
there's really beautiful work on it lots
of people study it
but i have just a hard time motivating
what the big questions are and so i
don't actually lecture on memory and i'm
really embarrassed about that but i just
haven't figured out how to give a good
lecture on it
that's one
emotions i've never figured out how to
lecture about emotions and of course
everybody cares about them and they're
really important and there are
neural stories to be told
and experiments to read about and i am
just not very good on that topic
[Music]
if you have insights to share please get
in touch with us at the link in our show
notes and when you do you'll be joining
nancy in making cognitive neuroscience
more accessible to all of us
if you're interested in learning from
her open and free teaching materials or
remixing them in your own teaching you
can find them on our mit open courseware
website
additionally you can find nancy's work
at the mcgovern institute by visiting
mcgovern.mit.edu
thank you so much for listening until
next time signing off from cambridge
massachusetts i'm your host sarah hansen
from mit open courseware
chalk radio's producers include myself
brett pachi and dave lachansky script
writing assistance from nidhi shastri
show notes for this episode were written
by peter chipman
the 913 ocw course site was built by
sheba nemat nasser
we're funded by mit open learning and
supporters like you